while many on unemployment now heading
back to work there are still those that
are waiting for answers on their
benefits joe mohler joining us live in
our newsroom he spoke to two people who
filed appeals with unemployment and joe
they're still waiting brian that's right
people who did not agree with the
decision made by the unemployment office
filed appeals during that process their
payments stopped and a lot of people are
still waiting for an answer
robert walker's payments stopped after
he got a letter stating he owes three
thousand dollars for not proving he was
looking for work he has been waiting for
an appeal since the summer i did file
all my
looking for work
so i was like wait a minute i know i'm
not crazy here now because i did it
exactly the way they asked me to do it i
also caught up with jason letona his
appeal hearing date was friday morning
he tells me he missed the call by
seconds he showed us he called right
back and could knock it through now he
does not know what to do by the time i
hung up i saw i had a voicemail come
through i listened to it i was told that
because i didn't answer the phone at 8
15 even though i technically was called
816
he was one minute late that my case is
now dismissed and to have a pleasant day
frustrations for months for those who
have been trying to get answers have
been trying to get through on the phone
that's been a problem we've seen
throughout the pandemic well we did
reach out to dieter this morning to see
if we could get some answers we're still
waiting on a response a month ago i was
told there is no estimated timeline on
how long those appeals could take as
soon as we learn more we'll be short to
update this story reporting the newsroom
i'm joe mohler i'll send it back to you